you've heard it before the movie trailer
that starts with in a world but before
movies can be made
someone has to build those walls and
that's where the production designer
comes in often working off of nothing
but a single line in a script the
production designer dreams it draws it
and makes it real here are the nominees
for achievement in production design the
grand Budapest hotel production design
by Adam Stockhausen and set decoration
by Anna Pennock the imitation game
production design by Maria Djokovic and
set decoration by Tatiana McDonald
interstellar production design by nathan
crowley and set decoration by gary fetes
into the woods production design by
Dennis Gassner and set decoration by
anna panic
mr Turner production design by Suzy
Davies and set decoration by Charlotte
Watts and the Oscar goes to the grand
Budapest hotel
thank you to the Academy for this award
and thank you thank you thank you to Wes
Anderson for making this beautiful film
Wes making the grand Budapest with you
was a dream come true and I just I can't
say thank you enough thanks as well to
rave Tony and the magnificent cast -
Steven rail Scott Rudin Jeremy Dawson
and thank you to our art department
we're here because of the tremendous
effort of our whole team from
set-dressing and construction to
graphics and props we're so so proud of
you all tonight we share this award with
you and finally thank you to my family
to my teachers and to a fella named Mark
Friedberg who gave me my start and
showed me how it's done right
brilliant script